tonight the indians get a look at
another youngster who's got a chance to
be a dominant pitcher for a long time to
come in the american league central his
name is casey mize he's a right-hander
frankie lindor leads off batting
left-handed shows bunty buns it down the
third base line quickly off the mound
mize turns flips to first to candelario
lindor tried to burn his way on but one
of the many things that casey meyers
does well is also field his position
that'll bring up cesar hernandez the
switch hitter ground ball chopped up the
middle scooping it up behind second
willy castro easy flip over to first and
two easy outs to start tonight's ball
game for casey mize jose ramirez at the
plate jose ramirez has gone seven for 24
against detroit pitching this year as
ramirez gets into one deep right field
back is cameron he's out of room it's
out of here
and jose ramirez oh he loves him some
motor city and the indians have a
one-nothing lead here in inning number
one that'll bring up carlos santana
switch hitter batting left-handed
swinging a high fly ball
shallow center field late break for
reyes but he'll come in make the easy
grab and that'll do it shane bieber who
if the vote were taken now would be the
unanimous winner the american league cy
young works with a one-nothing lead
going to the bottom of the first reyes
swings and misses at a 95 mile an hour
heater away and we'll see if that's
really a sign of things to come and it's
swung on and missed another fastball
away and bieber strikes out his second
and he gets him to pop it up
shallow center field coming in as
mercado and a strong first inning for
shane bieber as the tigers go in order
shane bieber will face the middle of the
tigers order as the indians and the
tigers go to the bottom of the second
the pitch swing and a miss good
curveball and he gets good from and he's
got three strikeouts already and it's
strike three called on the outside
corner my goodness does shane bieber
look good tonight he has struck out four
indians have a lead off base runner here
in the fourth inning here's jose ramirez
officially it's jose ramirez's birthday
he's 28 years old i don't think
anybody's going to catch that one he is
going going gone for the second time
tonight jose ramirez having himself
quite a birthday bash in the motor city
and the indians now lead it by a score
of three nothing so now casey mize is in
trouble and the bases are loaded and now
it's up to oscar mercado with two down
eighth man to bat in the inning tops it
to third and it's off the glove of
paradise the indians will pick up
another run and it's now four to nothing
cleveland what a break for the try boy
and this is where the tigers might be
really careful with mize as his defense
is not helping him top of the lineup
francisco lindor steps in ball four
and another run in the indians have
scored four times here in the fourth and
that's going to be it for the youngster
casey mize ron gardner has made the call
to nick ramirez tigers need to go to
their bullpen to get out of the bases
loaded jam here three pitches gets it
done for ramirez to get out of the
fourth bieber through the first three
innings a lot of fastballs from him
today establishing that early bieber
with four strikeouts and allowed just
the one base hit breaking ball did he
check it no he went too far
on that nasty slider by shane bieber the
strikeout victim the fifth for shane
bieber breaking ball swung on and missed
strike three
he swung at that pitch and then
just looked out at bieber as if to say
all right you got me but that's what
bieber does he gets such great late
break on his breaking stuff swung on and
missed strike three bieber now with
seven strikeouts bases are loaded you
hate to see front middle ray is stepping
to the plate but he is that ball up the
middle it gets through for front neil
reyes that's going to get home hernandez
here comes jose ramirez and front meal
reyes makes it a seven nothing ball game
here's tyler naquin one for three with a
single and he hits a ground ball
nicely played by the shortstop and they
cannot turn the double play and another
run
comes home it's eight nothing indians
runner on with two down cesar hernandez
the banner going the other way again
long run can't get it bonifacio unable
to corral it coming around third josh
naylor is going to be waved home and he
will score makes it nine to nothing
cleveland jose ramirez the birthday boy
plus the bat and he shoots it through
oh my what a birthday for ramirez his
fourth hit of the night
he picks up his fourth run batted in
shane bieber with a two hit shot out a
strikeout eight and walked one romine
swings and misses another breaking ball
that bounced in there romaine just turns
and walks away said don't bother tagging
me i quit how many times have we seen
them swing at balls bouncing in there
cameron swings through a fastball that
is strikeout number ten
for shane bieber and he's done it again
another double-digit strikeout game
seven out of the 11 starts bieber has
struck out 10 or more and shane bieber
convinced sandy alamar look i'm at 114
pitches i've got enough in the tank and
so he will stay in there bieber laboring
now you can tell he's got the fuel tank
just about on empty ripped down the
right field line
and that ball is gone
willy castro goes yard a three-run blast
gets the tigers on the board there goes
bieber shutout still a magnificent
effort shane bieber went seven and two
thirds innings struck out ten walk two
two down last hope for the tigers jorge
bonifacio swing and a miss ball game and
the indians eight games of misery is
over